Bobby Brown welcomes a baby girl the R&B singers wife Alicia Etheridge went into labor at cedars-sinai hospital in LA over the weekend welcoming a baby girl Saturday the couple who Wed in 2012 also share five year old son Cassius making this new little one Alicia's second child and Bobby six but of course this exciting baby news comes at a difficult time Brown has been dealing with the sad situation surrounding his 22 year old daughter Bobbi Kristina in January she was found unresponsive in a bathtub in her Georgia home the daughter of the late Whitney Houston was placed in a medically induced coma then moved to hospice care in June